if there's one thing the Metal Gear
Solid series knows how to do it's
confused the bejesus out of me now don't
get me wrong though I love it but what
is with that vampire guy you can run a
water those robots that move oh yeah and
that man made of bees drunk no not him
bees okay maybe it wasn't bee Hornets
whatever what was his deal we are the
sons of the bar anyway I'm a bit of a
science nerd I know you're shocked
so one central theme from the Metal Gear
series that has always appealed to me is
the origins of solid and liquid snake
specifically the fact that they are both
clones of big boss the legendary soldier
and protagonist of ground zeroes so
could we actually clone big boss using
modern science in real life
lizz all fall Torre blur a United States
government project designed to create
two clones of Big Boss the so called
Twin Snakes solid and liquid why well as
the story goes Big Boss was rendered
sterile due to radiation exposure during
a nuclear test and the top brass in
charge didn't want to lose all his
incredible soldier genetics should he
happen to die so they decided to clone
him and to do this they used a technique
called somatic cell cloning okay so far
so good
their exposure to radiation can indeed
cause someone to become sterile and
somatic cell cloning is a real thing
although more accurately it's known as
somatic cell nuclear transfer now the
technique requires two things number one
a somatic cell from the person you want
to clone now this is any cell in the
body really containing DNA other than an
egg or a sperm that these are known as
germ cells and number two an
unfertilized egg cell from a donor first
off the nucleus of the egg cell that's
the part that contains all of the DNA is
removed and discarded then the nucleus
from the somatic cell is transferred to
the waiting egg so now we have an egg
containing all the DNA it needs to
divide grow and eventually become a
living thing all that needs to happen
next is a few chemical nudges to get the
process going and then a ready and
willing surrogate mother to have the egg
embedded in their uterus for nine months
now because DNA is the blueprint for the
living thing the resulting child will be
genetically identical to the donor of
the somatic cell okay now this is a bit
of bonus science because technically a
clone is not 100% genetically identical
to the original the reason is because of
mitochondrial DNA so what's that
well mitochondria are tiny little energy
factories which sit inside the cytoplasm
of our cells they also have their own
DNA which by the way is always passed on
by our mothers as the egg is where the
mitochondrial
so in the world of metal gear while Big
Boss would have the mitochondrial DNA of
his natural mother both solid and liquid
snake would have the mitochondrial DNA
of the egg donor now in real life this
technique has been used to clone a
number of different animal species on
the list of successes we have Dolly the
trendsetting sheep cows pigs mice and
even rare creatures like Gower and
mufflon yes these are real animals but
what about humans well it is a bit
complicated now they're almost certainly
no cloned humans walking around in the
world today
however just last year a team of
scientists did successfully create a
clean human embryo through this somatic
cell nuclear transfer the reason was to
use this embryo as a source for
embryonic stem cells which are
invaluable in the development of new
medical research and treatments so while
there are no clone humans alive today
this research further demonstrates that
there's nothing impossible about human
cloning it would however be both messy
and tricky easy cloning is not a precise
or reliable science to say the least
even today animal cloning is still
fraught with failure the majority of
embryos don't survive and most of those
that do make it to pregnancy result in
miscarriage so if you were going to
clone a human it would result in a large
number of failed attempts and take a
really long time
however credit to Metal Gear Solid lore
it does mention that there were numerous
failed attempts during resolve on
cerebral project so overall as the
science goes the series is pretty much
spot-on with the cloning of Big Boss
there are however a ton of legal and
ethical reasons why not to mind you but
that's a discussion for a different show
okay so while it is possible Wood
cloning a Super Soldier actually mean
that the clones are also great at being
soldiers well not necessarily now I
don't want to get sucked into a whole
nature vs. nurture debate at this point
but the fact is that as humans we are a
product of both our genetics and our
environment so sure big boss might have
a load of genetic traits on his side
which helped him to be a badass soldier
perhaps higher than average muscle mass
say or increased oxygen carrying
capacity of the hemoglobin in his blood
for that said it doesn't mean the clone
of a gift
will necessarily be equally good at
soldiering and most you could say they
are predisposed to being a great soldier
but ultimately training and upbringing
are absolutely crucial when it comes to
developing strength skill and
intelligence all cloning really does is
rewind to time zero and then start again
the environment then begins to affect
the clone in entirely new ways resulting
in a different person even if
genetically they would be identical okay
but what about the negative side effects
of cloning and Metal Gear Solid 4 we
clearly see Solid Snake's suffering from
accelerated aging but is this actually a
problem with real-life cloning well
Dolly the sheep the first mammal to be
cloned did die at a young age of just
six usually sheep of the same species
lived twice that long at the time the
blame was leveled at Dolly's telomeres
which were shorter than they should have
been for a sheep of her age a telltale
sign of premature aging so what's a
telomere then well there are little bits
of DNA that have been compared to the
little plastic tips you get on shoelaces
that's because their job is to keep
chromosome ends from fraying and
sticking to each other which would
destroy or scramble an organisms genetic
information
however since Dolly's death many cloned
animals have gone on to live lives of a
normal length casting doubt on premature
aging being an unavoidable side-effect
of cloning in fact just last year
researchers from the righthand Center
for developmental biology in Kobe Japan
identified a way to produce healthy
Mouse clones that live a normal lifespan
and can also be sequentially cloned
indefinitely so what do you think of
this episode and the idea of human
cloning let me know in the comments box
down below or by tweeting directly at me
at kam fries Rob last week on reality
check I investigated the science of
getting in the zone
while playing a game also known as
cognitive flow subsequently I was
helpfully sent a bunch of great
resources for further reading by dr.
Nick Bowman assistant professor and
research associate at the media and
interaction lab at West Virginia
University check out his work if you
want to learn more about this
fascinating topic the links are on
screen now thanks Nick
okay that's it for this week thanks for
watching and see you back here next
Sunday for more reality check